okay um is that too loud that sound
good um thank you all so much for uh
coming this talk to the end the day I'm
going to be talking about shiny which is
a python web application framework um
and I think the sort of where I wanted
to start this talk was to talk about
sort of how data scientists kind of
actually deliver value so my background
is as a data scientist been working um
there for about you know 10 years or so
until I moved over to do um software
engineering and what I kind of always
noticed is that data science has kind of
a last mile problem you do a ton of work
to gather data to get access to that
data to find a place to analyze it do
the analysis build the model and then at
the end of the day you kind of have to
deliver it and that point of delivery is
where your company starts getting value
from your work but that point of
delivery is really difficult um you
often have to wait for I think
especially in a python world you have to
wait for quod quotee real web developer
to come in and build the product that is
going to deliver your analysis to
stakeholders people actually pay your
bills this is really expensive you know
as you saw highi have that great case
study it's really expensive to hire
somebody from outside of your company
find web developers in your current
company get it on their road map um it
takes forever to do this type of work by
the nature of kind of the Frameworks
that those people use and most
importantly it's often incorrect right
in order to deliver a really good data
science product you need to have
intuition about your data and a generic
web developer often doesn't have that
right so they might present the data in
such a way that's confusing or
inaccurate and then you have to go
through this whole process again right
so why can't we just do it ourselves and
I think the main reason why we can't do
it ourselves is that whenever you're
delivering one of these products it's
kind of like getting a puppy right you
put it in front of people they like it
they want more from it and it starts to
grow right so you need to have a
framework which can grow with that
problem and and most of the uh available
application Frameworks don't just to
give you a kind of example of this when
I was at socure we were the data science
was uh putting together a feature
management API the idea behind this was
it was a central Source where everyone
in the company could get information
about our machine learning features
where they came from what they were
called how they fit together um it's
developed by data science team and was
important right it was something that
was going to be used by more or less the
whole company but it needed a front end
so when we looked at all the tools that
we had available to ourselves none of
them really fit they were either kind of
too hard for the data science team to
use or they were too limited for that
product to grow or we thought it would
grow right so we needed something which
could grow streamlet looked pretty
fragile in terms of re executing
everything all the time um when we
looked at Dash this restriction on
having only stateless components so you
couldn't really share data between
graphs or between graphs and plots seems
pretty awkward um and none of us knew
JavaScript so we were kind of stuck and
ended up need to basically wait I think
9 months before we ended up getting the
hire approved hiring the person
onboarding that person and building that
application so shiny is designed for
that problem right it's designed to grow
and this makes it a little bit um
difficult to talk about in a demo right
because I can't show you a big
application that's going to grow in 40
minutes right and that's really where
this framework shines it's very simple
to get started but it has all the tools
you need to build um full products it's
all in Python there's an R version like
the historical version of sh shiny it
was Rewritten last year in Python um
it's easy enough to build a prototype
but it has the tools that you need to
build a product right but showing that
growth is complicated right so what I'm
going to do instead is I'm going to talk
about Chinese algorithm and try to sort
of develop a little bit of an intuition
about how shiny actually does this work
what's special about it and how it works
right so let's take a look at a at a
example so this is a three-page app and
I'm just going to sort of tell this
story for each page I think this kind of
shows a little bit of how these grow so
this is a kind of example of a basic
training dashboard you know maybe I fit
a model and I want to just expose it to
stakeholders so that they can check
their accounts that are going to be
hitting this model to make sure the
model performs as well for that
particular account as it does in jav
model right so I have two little plots
shows model score and a little RSC curve
um and the user can change what um plot
they
want and so what's interesting about
shiny is that um when I update this
uh metric the only plock that actually
fires or changes is this one nothing
happens over here um but if I change the
account since both of them depend on
that account slider both change right so
it's minimally rendering things it's
only rendering the parts of my
application that needs need to change in
response to a particular user
action but how does it do that right so
this is the full code that generates
those plots and one of the things that
kind of look at this code if you're if
you have some backgrounded web
development and it's a little weird
right there's no call backs here right
there no state so how is it that chines
is figuring out how to render things in
this really efficient way another way of
putting this is we told shiny what to do
right we said here's how you make these
plots but we never told it when to do it
but somehow shiny knows how to knows
when to do it and it more or less always
gets that
ready so how do other Frameworks
accomplish this right so stream L
approach is is great especially for
simple applications but pretty blunt um
for larger ones which just reenders
everything you just start from the
beginning rerender everything so I don't
need to figure out how things should
update I just rerender everything and
you know you can kind of get more into
the weeds of state and caching uh later
but beginning that's kind of how it
works and most other uh Frameworks use
event handling um what a event handling
is is you the programmer Define when
things should fire when your renderers
should fire so you say when this button
changes on click on change do this this
action and it has some problems I think
the first one is you have to to do it so
as a data scientist that's a little much
I think doing it and doing it correctly
is hard um it's pretty easy to get wrong
right if you fire call backs in the
wrong order you update state in one part
of your application and not another um
you can get these kind of percious bugs
where you show the user the wrong value
and importantly it's really hard to tell
when you get it wrong sometimes you need
to kind of get into a particular State
you testing to trigger that sort of
value so usually when event handling
goes wrong it's not you don't get a
failure you get an incorrect value
somewhere deep in your application my
favorite example of this is slack so
about every 3 weeks I get an unism slack
notification that says you have activity
go deal with your activity and I click
and I don't have any activity and I just
know deep in my heart somewhere in the
slack event handling artifice somebody
in there has forgotten to update a state
variable or she's forgotten to retrieve
a state variable and I'm the one who has
to suffer for it um so what's a better
way a better way is I you know you can
think about Downs right so directed
basic graphs are great because you know
that for any particular Upstream change
which nodes need to change Downstream
right that's that's wonderful this is
something we use in make files airf flow
all over the place right it's a very
good way of figuring out that problem of
what needs to reexecute but the problem
is you still have to write this if you
write this wrong your application's
going to be wrong so is there a way we
could maybe avoid writing this at all so
here's shiny strategy shiny Str is to
infer all the relationships between your
component from your
application and use that inference to
build a computation graph and use that
computation graph to minimally reexecute
your application
right okay so like telling you that I'm
doing this kind of like magic inference
and like I would just suggest that that
should create a little bit of Suspicion
right because often times you get these
inferences and they're like 85% right
and that's much worse than just not
doing at all right like I don't want to
have an inference if it's not rock Sol
right and so like this is a good face
good face to from from Larry so for this
to work it has to work all the time 100%
of the time because if it misses one
then you're not going to be able to
trust it and you're going to have to do
the inent handling anyway and it's if
you can't trust that inference it's not
useful to
you so one question then is like okay
how would we do this right let's just
start from scratch like how would you do
this and one answer you might think of
is we could analyze the source code
right so it have these inputs here those
inputs are likely user inputs so maybe I
could read all the source code I could
parse it find all those inputs and use
those to draw that down right and that
might you could sort of think okay that
might work it it would be hard right but
it might work but it won't work um and
the reason it won't work is because um
shiny allows Dynamic user interfaces so
this is a to-do list um so if I like say
buy groceries I can add a bunch of these
tasks I can complete these tasks and
clear them and things go away right so
at any given point in this application
the application state has depends on all
the things that the user has done up
until that point right another way of
putting that is that this particular
application state is not in the source
code right and it's very difficult
therefore to use static code analysis to
get that application state so it's not
going to
work instead what chiny does is runtime
tracing so at runtime while your
application is running it just watches
what all of the different components
asked for and it writes that down says
okay you asked for this thing last time
I'm going to know that when you when
that changes I'm going to ask you to
reender right because I I remember that
you asked it I don't really care about
what's happening in the code I just know
that you made a request for this thing
and that thing is a reactive thing so
I'm going to like just keep track of
that but what happens inside you know
not really my
business so how does this here's a kind
of just walk you through a really basic
example so user asks for this output so
this is an output on theen screen called
Tex is the ID um shiny then goes and
finds the rendering function that
matches that ID and fires it and uh when
it fires the rendering function you see
there's this input call so that's a call
out to an input from the UI um and then
chiny goes and gets the value of that UI
and Records all of those steps right in
a simplified way you get this little
graph you get one input to one output
most of the rest of this talk is just
going to be about these beautiful Little
Mermaid graphs you say myself um so
let's just uh just refresh our memory
about what this looks like right so I
have two inputs and two outputs like the
count input the metric input and then
the model metrics plot and the
distribution
here and when shiny starts out this is
all it knows it just knows that there
are four things two of them are inputs
and two of them are outputs has no idea
about any of the relationships between
and so it's like okay I don't have any
idea what's going to happen so let's
just try to get one of these Outlets
pick one I'm going to pick the metric
plot so it calculates the metric plot
and the metric plot goes out and
requests the selector and the account
selector right those are the two things
it needs to generate its plot CH does
that and draws these two
lines and the distribution plot fires
and that only needs the account selector
so the model metric doesn't
matter and there we have our graph no
static code analysis
required so when the account changes um
shiny does something called invalidate
what that means is it tells the
downstream dependencies you're not good
anymore you need to recalculate so it
invalidates those those two outputs and
when things are invalidated it just
forgets everything that it knows about
those relationships again this is all
happening at runtime so well those
relationships were that was the
relationships before might not be the
relationship now when I recalculate so
it recalculates and in this case it gets
the same graph goes and gets these two
inputs tries to calculate the
distribution gets the account SEL ctor
and we're
back if the metric changes though uh
something different happens right
because the metric only has one child
node so that's the only one that
invalidates but the distribution plot
doesn't need to invalidate right it
didn't depend on Metric so it's still
good it doesn't need to recalculate but
you still forget the dependencies from
the inated nodes and then recalculate it
so go get the two values and we're done
right so this is the kind of Secret of
how sh is able to let you build very
performant applications with very low
workload as a developer right I don't
need to as a developer keep track of
this graph really in any way I need to
tell shiny and declare shiny this is
what I think these should these how
these things should be drawn but then
shiny is able to infer from that as that
application runs how those things should
be rendered so I've kind of like I'm
stepping one level up in abstraction
right I'm not kind of doing the cooking
I'm setting the menu right and this
frees you from a lot of work as a
web so this graph we showed like
everything was the same right came to
the same conclusion so it seems like a
little bit of a lot of work that it's
forgetting everything um but shiny
actually can do graphs that do change
and this is pretty common so here I have
a really simple example where I have one
slider um I have I have a button which
tells shiny which slider it should use
it should listen to and when I change
this slider nothing changes but if I
want say change slider one
the text changes and if I switch this
and I go to sh two now slider one is
ignored and slider two uh response right
and here's the code that's doing that
rer so and basically just it's just a
simple conditional where if it's slider
one I'm returning one slider value and
otherwise I'm returning another
one so again shiny knows nothing about
this application it just knows that
there are three inputs and one output
tries to calculate the text output
initially in the first thing it needs is
like I'm doing that conditional which
button which slider should be following
go get the buttons value and then it
knows to go get the slider value and
we're finished right never got to input
slider
two so then when slider two changes
nothing happens right and I just want to
pause for a second and explain like why
that's correct so when we ran that first
function it said it came to its
conclusion without ever asking for the
value of slider two what that means that
is that for all possible values of
slider two this output is the same and
if that's true that means that if slider
two changes we can just ignore it right
because for all that possible values of
that the output ended up being the
same so slider one changes this kind of
the same process where the text output
invalidates it goes and gets the button
button still slider one so it changes to
slider one but if the buttons change
when it invalidates text text output and
goes and gets the new value button which
it says go look at slider two this time
it's going to get slider to right and we
have a different graph so that's kind of
why we have this process of things
changing because the reactive graph is
going to change over the course of that
user's application and again for those
Dynamic UI elements where you're adding
and removing things or things are
changing based on other values this is
really important because you might
actually add or remove nodes from this
graph based on what based on what has
happened previously to that uh in that
session um any questions about
that
okay that's either very clear or
incredibly unclear so let's power
through um so what's great about this
pattern is that it scales so every
single shiny app uses this exact pattern
there's no like way of developing
complex shining app versus simple
shining apps right they all
fundamentally use this type of
transparent reactivity and you can kind
of imagine how this scals right dieses
are very efficient at rendering so if I
had lots and lots of components assuming
that chin is going to be able to use
this same process to put it into a dag
it's going to be able to render those
very complicated
applications um this works for diami and
lastly it's lazy um so because it's
starting out at the bottom of that graph
where the user is asking for something
if something is hidden from the user it
never gets calculated right until the
user actually goes and asks for
it um so I'll give you a kind of example
of this so here I have these like three
tabs with stuff happening on them but
the training Dash is the only one that
actually in computation is happening
because the user hasn't asked for
anything on these background tabs right
so well Shin kind of ATT has attached
them to the Dom they're not
calculating okay so that's um so that's
what like we've kind kind of been
working with shallow graphs like
everything is all the inputs are being
directly consumed by an output and
that's great kind of like these simple
cases it works really well um but it's
pretty limited right particular like
each of those rendering functions it's
kind of working like Dash they're doing
all of the work they need to calculate
and they're not really able to share
common calculations so there's kind of
repetition there might be repetition
between them and that kind of limits its
efficiency so we have a concept called a
reactive calculation and what a reactive
calculation does is it's basically a way
of uh creating a function in this
reactive Paradigm so it creates a
calculation whose results can be used by
other functions either other reactive
calculations or other renderers this
basically adds depth to a graph
so let's take a look at this um model
monitoring so this is an example of it
growing everyone's happy with my model
I've deployed it and now I need to keep
track of it and this is a production
there's lots of data coming in so I need
to have some way of basically like
taking a sample and investigating it so
the idea here is that I'm able to
specify a date range um create a sample
size and this is going to query a
database to bring in my sample but I can
still flip through these accounts in
memory so this will pull the data for
all the accounts that I have and so that
account will be really fast even if the
sample maybe is a little
slow so what do I want from
this so I want to query that database
between to get that sample and then
later on I want to filter that sample in
memory I don't want to have to go back
to the database I want to have that
filter in I'm going to send that same
data to the two functions without doing
the filter again and without doing the
sample I want to send that data I want
to cach the results of all of those
queries want to invalidate the cach
whenever its Upstream dependencies
change and I don't want to do any
thinking or work right I don't want to
have to worry about this at all I'm a
data scientists I'm not good at that
stuff so I just want to have it you know
do have handle have it be handled for
and so this is I think the one of the
core things about shiny is that there
are other python application Frameworks
that can do some of these things but
none of them can do all of them in
particular I think none of them can do
four five and six together right so how
does chiny do four five and six together
so we have this reactive Cal decorator
and what that does is it caches its
value right so whenever it runs the
first time it runs it cashes its value
so you can achieve you can call it reply
and it's PL it sticks that reactive
calculation in the same reactive graph
so it discards the cache whenever it's
Upstream whenever it's invalidated and
it tells its descendants that they need
to be invalidated just like the
input um so this is how you would might
look might code this uh that example so
we see we have two reactives here one is
the sample data that handles that query
step querying the database and then the
second one is um this filter data that
does the account filter and what how you
call these is you basically just call
them as functions so in the filter data
is calling sample data and then when I
have this plot scores it's calling
filtered
data so I have these little hexagons to
kind of indicate reactive calculations
but again chiny when it starts it
doesn't know how these things are
related it just knows that there's three
inputs two reactive calculations and two
plots and it starts from the bottom and
just tries to calculate the model score
so calculates the model score model
score goes and says I need that filter
data filter data requires the account
and the sample reactive calculation that
sample reactive calculation then runs
and it says oh I need the dates and the
sample size in order to get the sample
it does that passes the data down to
model for plots produced but when the
API response calls this just needs the
filtered data right it needs the exact
same thing as model SC so nothing is
calculated right no filtering is done no
sampling is done it just goes and
retrieves the cache right um but when
things are so this is that's how the
caching works when the evalation works
happens basically so if account changes
um it sort of does the same thing it
tells its descendants you're a knowledge
right so filter is invalid it needs to
recalculate filter goes and tells its
children hey you're invalid too and they
forget everything that they knew about
their previous dependencies then the
same process goes model scores runs gets
filtered this time it doesn't again
doesn't take a fresh sample because the
Upstream that was sampled hasn't changed
right so and that's important because
when you whenever you're doing these
kind of sampling operations you want to
have going to take your sample once and
interrogate that same sample in many
places right so if you're not doing this
type of caching with sampling you might
end up with this place where whenever I
change the account I'm taking a fresh
sample and I'm getting like actually
inaccurate um intuition about it because
it might be one sample shows one value
another sample shows another one when I
really want to just investigate that
same
sample and API response doesn't same
thing as always does which is it just
gets cash value It
Go um when something UPS further
Upstream changes the whole graph gets
invalidated so when sample chat size
changes we do need to go get a new
sample from the database so sample
invalidates filter invalidates plots
invalidate and we're back to our initial
State not knowing anything about this
application and go out and get our same
uh inputs and outputs and an API
response again just gets it cash
value so this lets you build up kind of
arbit pretty arbitrarily complex
applications because you can stack these
reactive calculations as deep as you
need to right um and they're always
going to do effectively the minimum
amount of work that you want to use that
they need to in order to um generate
your application so whenever you're
developing chiny apps it's pretty
important to stick to a pretty strict do
not repeat yourself rule both because it
keeps your code in one place but also
because by avoiding repetition with
reactive calculations you actually make
your whole application much more
efficient okay any questions about
that yes uh how are you so what criteria
are you using to determine it uh data
are you looking at the values that we
retrieved by the input function no we're
not we're just using we're just using a
graph okay right so we don't we don't
know we're not like and this is also
important because we're not like caching
that to dis or cashing that in memory
like hashing the whole big data frame
we're just holding the object in memory
and knowing that um that like the way
we're determining whether it needs to
change or not is basically did my parent
noes change okay so if I count a then B
then
a the whole thing triggers again yes
second okay cuz again shiny doesn't
isn't like yeah so there are ways of
doing that type of caching and shiny too
um where you are sort of saying like I
want to just check that the value but
the problem is that like that check
isn't free right so if I'm doing that
hashing I have to do a hash and a hash
comparison which if it's a giant data
set might actually be more expensive
than the filter doing the filter twice
right so you can do that but it's not
automatic right the automatic thing is
that we're just going to hold the result
of that filter calculation and determine
it based on the graph great
question okay um so reactivity is a
great default right this idea just let
to infer how things should work manage
State and caching and caching validation
for you um but it's not the only thing
right not everything fits this pattern
perfectly so sometimes you actually do
want to specify I want this to happen
when that happens right you do want to
do it hand so an example is like
batching inputs or triggering a side
effect um and event programming it's not
all bad the problem is just like when
you use it for everything you can run
into these mistakes right um so an
example of this is this is again my my
application growing so here maybe I've
determined that like my model isn't
doing very well so I need to like do
some data updating and I have these
little buttons where I'm just saying
like reading something being like that
looks like
Electronics you know and this is like
obviously not the thing that people
dream of when they're doing data science
school but you know it's turns out it's
super
important and I won't bore you very much
about this but every time I change this
it's basically like writing an
annotation to a CSV file um so that's
like doesn't fit very well with this
idea of a reactive graph right because I
I don't really want the value I want to
trigger some sort of thing outside of my
application update a database play model
something like that so we don't want
this to react automatically we want to
specify like the user what happens when
that button is clicked um so we have
these Decor this decorator called
reactive effect there two ones that go
together often reactive effect and
reactive event um so reactive effect uh
indicates that this is a side effect so
it's I shouldn't I shouldn't return a
value from that function I just want the
side effect to occur um and reactive
event says like what's the trigger for
that event and this can be inputs it can
also be reactive calculations and the
one key Point here is I'm referring to
this um input as an object this is a
callable object so I'm not when you want
the value you call it but if you just
want to say like pay attention to this
thing whenever this thing changes make a
you know fire this function um you just
call it as a as as the raw object and
then we have this um body of the
function that defines what that
calculation is so this is how you would
do something like a side effect or or
you know an API call or something like
or posting an API or play or something
like
that um so reactive event can also be
paired with um renderers or reactive
counts if you don't for whatever reason
Chinese magic Chinese inference isn't
working you want to like override it and
say like an example is you have five
inputs in a form and you want them all
to only to go together with a best
button input that would be AE you would
want to maybe have a reactive event on
top of your reactive C and basically
says like ignore all of the other
dependencies and just use this one this
is the only dependency you should
use and the way I sort of think about
this is it's kind of like adding like an
VRI chocolate chips to the broader
reactive cookie so you don't want to do
this all the time most of the work is
reactivity transparent reactivity but
you sometimes do want to have these
little like uh event patterns in there
um and one thing I have found especially
from people who are transitioning from
an event than front end framework
especially JavaScript is they they're
kind of uncomfortable by how little work
they have to do in Chinese so they kind
of start using reactive events
everywhere and that's like I would sort
of say that's a code smell so you want
to just try to you noticed yourself
doing that just relax you don't actually
need to do that much work it is normal
to feel that way um and uh yes so you
want to try to rely on reactivity but
then if you need to override it for
whatever reason active events the way to
go um and the the last thing is that
reactive events and reactive reactive
effects and reactive calculations
basically the intuition there is
reactive effects are for side effects
reactive calculations are for values so
side effects are things that happen
outside of the world of your application
like updating a database or writing to a
CSV file playing model something like
that and reactive calculations are for
values like you have a calculation you
know write there in the name fetching a
data from a database that's usually one
the value of that data you don't want
the act of fetching it um or filtering
data
frame um so one thing I just ask you I'm
going to be have the posit boo is you
should think a little bit about this
pattern and ways that it would fall down
um we have a lot of other functions that
I'm not going to get to today that kind
of cover those so reactive isolate is to
prevent Cycles in your graph if you need
to include data like a database or some
external object as part of that reactive
graph like you have an airflow pipeline
that's dumping a file and you want your
app to always react to the changes in
that file um reactive Pole or reactive
fire file reader do that um if you want
something to react to time basically
like invalidate every five minutes on a
cycle we have invalidate lader and you
can store variables with reactive value
so if you ever have a an a side effect
that you want to then trigger reactive
the rest of your reactive graph reactive
value is how you do
that so in summary shiny creates very
performant apps with very little work
right and this is its color feature that
and as your application grows that's
more and more valuable right it's
valuable right at the beginning but
especially when you're kind of managing
larger complicated applications it's a
lifesaver this algorithm is is very
elegant I think but it's not magic right
there's nothing that not difficult to
understand here and there's nothing that
you can't really develop an intuition
about um and then overall I would say
it's important that whatever framework
you pick but like your users are guiding
how your application looks and feels not
the limitations of your framework right
so you want to have a framework that
gives you the flexibility that you need
to really accomplish the things that
your users wants you to do and choosing
a framework that can grow is super
important um so thank you I um I have
some a couple of minutes to take uh some
questions I think I'm about uh six
minutes early but um I'll also be around
the booth today or tomorrow um so if you
want to come by pause booth and chat
with with the rest of the team if happy
to do that any
questions all right well oh yeah go
ahead okay one more uh so I just to make
sure I follow you so that
does that basically get rebuilt every
time one of those Downstream inputs
changes yes so anytime there's like
something happens with the graph parts
of it get rebu like so the parts that
are invalidated get rebuil the parts
that are not invalidated you know that
those values are all good
so
yeah R have identical Fe sets or is
there slightly different and what's the
sort
of
yeah so there's two I would say there so
the question is like shiny for and shiny
for python do they have identical
feature sets so there's two parts to
that so one is the shiny core library
and then the second one is the broader
shiny community so I would say like
right now the core library for shiny for
shiny for python are pretty close um the
main are markable State some things like
that but in terms of like the main
features uh they're pretty they're very
similar um the community is it's a newer
package the community is much smaller so
we don't quite have the same wi feature
of extensions
um so we have a plan of kind of
continuing to bring the core Library
closer to it but the most of the stuff
that we have now that's missing are
things that um new users don't use all
that much so our focus is more on like
improving the early experience of shiny
which there'll be some Divergence I
think over these those two libraries um
because they are just different discrete
projects um but yeah they're pretty
close and shin for python also has most
of the PS components as well so same
yeah uh how customizable is the frend
like if you wanted to do styling and
yeah so fully um so it's so you can do
so all of those um like all of our
inputs have just basically like a CSS
class you can change those most of them
takes take CSS Styles directly um you
can include um arbitrary CSS or
JavaScript on top of it um we also have
um some new documentation that's coming
out in terms of extending like including
JavaScript new JavaScript components as
part of your application so that's also
possible where you can basically like
write um like write your own component
and have that component react to all the
other components as well um so that's
that's possible today we just haven't
written down we were in today writing it
down um and so that's another thing that
and that's that's again like the history
of shining is is from people who did web
development JavaScript web development
so that was kind of like table Stakes I
would say for them just basically like I
want all all the things that I need to
build
laration any other
questions two more minutes yeah can you
talk a little bit about how you define
the layout of that yeah was the main
point of
this so so basically the layout is
defined um it's look similar a little
similar to dash so we have like UI
functions that you m um inside of each
other um so that's basically like the
way so if you have like a sidebar
there's like a function like ui. page
sidebar so the UI sub module that has
all of our um user interface uh
components um and basically just kind of
mess those together um that can be
created however you like so you can
write it out but for a lot of times
people want to write functions that
render UI things like chunks of UI code
or S them than objects um we also have a
module system if you want to write
basically a function that includes both
a UI and a server element and kind of
those in their own file or share them
between applications so we have tools
for that but basically it's
like calling functions that say like
input call it this yeah ID this is the
ID yeah tempat here's your navigation
things and um yeah that's a pretty
robust way of doing it um we are kind of
also again in like a little bit of
process of seeing if we can create a
like simplified version of that that
maybe doesn't do quite as much but a
little easier to start um but uh that's
kind of a ear stage but but yeah so
that's the main pattern for doing that
and that's where you like Define those
IDs or what those inputs and outputs are
is that U UI
object okay um so I'll just let I'll be
here if you want to anyone wants to come
up with chat afterwards um just some
other things we do have a Discord which
is quite active so if you want to um
just join to ask questions uh that's a
great and yeah we'll you give it a try
and come talk to us far up around thank
you so much for your talk
[Applause]